a big Daft Punk guy on a little bit I
have no idea interesting dude
oh my God
[Music]
welcome to another very clean and
wholesome episode of careful boys super
careful we have with us Mr Kim come on
Lyft got over there too let's not let's
not clap go
Jesus Christ that is a nice class for
you that's Donkey Kong dude
Jesus Christ so I thought we would get
into our you know little personal side I
want to know
is there an item of any type that you
guys keep that holds extreme sentimental
value
what's yours you really you just you
already instantly have it what do you
have do you mean by like keep it on me
at all times you can or just you just I
have it it's a picture that my great
grandma made because my great grandma
was like one of our biggest I ever
tattooed across like my chest and
everything prove it
damn that was cool man that was cool and
uh so when I was a when I was young she
made this like she used to like knit or
whatever and she made this like picture
of these two owls and I've had it since
I was like four and I've lit Wow since
you were before yeah I've never every
place I've moved everything like that I
made sure I brought up so that's like
that's gonna stay with you 100 until I'm
dead that's really cool how big is it
huh
take
it
like that I don't know is that a normal
size picture I thought of like making
anything like like using it to make
something else or you just went I won't
ever touch it yeah I want to keep it as
is it's in the old like because it's old
like the the frame that it's in is like
just old school wooden like frame and
everything like that so yeah keep it
packed away anybody else have anything
off the top
is it crazy because I have a mediocre
one mine's mine's not that crazy it's
pretty good go ahead so uh when I was in
high school my dad bet me that I
wouldn't graduate
and uh if I did graduate then he was
gonna buy me a car and then so that's
pretty cool dude um once I was like set
to graduate he got me my first car which
is like a two it was a 2001 Civic EX
which was like you know a pretty much a
really great car it's a sweet car so
till this day I still have it I still
drive it around it's got a new motor
trans I upkeep it as much as possible I
spent way more money I think it's worth
um and dropped it I did yeah it's
ridiculously low and it's a little ricer
and it's just like an indicative of that
era that's the one you drove yeah yeah I
still drive it here yeah and it's super
sentimental to me because it's you know
I kind of knew like my dad knew that I
was gonna graduate he just said that
because he wanted to give it to me tough
guy style yeah yeah he don't want to
give it to you for free that's very like
he wants to like love me but like not in
a way that compromises his manhood you
know like so it's a very cool thing that
we have where we never really quite hug
but it's like yeah you know and uh that
car I'm gonna keep it for the rest of my
life like 100 percent
2001 so I'm not living in the freaking
Hot Import Nights past I'm just simply
uh sentimental you know yeah is it
two-door or whatever yeah it's a
two-door of course sweet I always like
the exes yeah I didn't realize that
there was such a Sentimental story
between I just thought you were living
in the import past the whole time we
thought that I am but
God that's just my style
all right what's your mediocre one yeah
yeah your turn and really cool can we
just let that breathe for one second
thank you
um so on my first date ever with Nina uh
I like took her to the you know just
this beach and stuff like that and then
uh there's people flying a car and I was
like oh that sounds really cute a kite
yeah and all did I tell the story yes
you told us about the first time you and
Nina but Steve ruined it when you told
it last time so you could do a clean run
lovely things in my life for sure but
it's the Kite from that story dude yeah
it is it is so uh uh I was like have you
ever flown a kite before thinking
rhetorically like who the [ __ ] doesn't
and she's like no I haven't I was like
what the [ __ ] so I was like so we just
[ __ ] loser yeah one of the one of the
little like random toy stores that was
around the area that like sells like
stuff for the beach you know like little
buckets that you can [ __ ] like
Superman or whatever yeah and there's
this uh kite there so we just got this
like generic you know off-brand blue
kite because blue is cool uh and then we
flew a kite and I was literally teaching
how to fly a kite this day and so in my
mind I was like whoa that was that was
crazy and just the fact that obviously
our relationship lasted I just kept that
blue kite and you know Granny you don't
fly guys all the time actually I don't
think I have a fluid again but I've
moved to like three or four places since
we started dating
um and every single time we moved it
would just be like oh the kite so we
always take it with us and now I just
feel like we're never gonna ditch it
yeah yeah yeah the first time that we
like for real that was our first date so
we have it tucked away collecting dust I
really like that yeah that's super cute
thank God Steve's not here I'm all right
to ruin this moment what was Steve
saying hey sorry man what would Steve
say about that all kinds of a [ __ ]
dancer oh my God
he slaughtered it last time don't you
remember what he did not bring it up he
dumped on it real hard is it what about
you do you have anything what about you
you got something sentimental everybody
went and I feel like serious fomo
because I'm really thinking in my head
I'm like I don't think there's anything
like
personal you don't get attached to just
like little objects or something you're
not gonna like hold on to the more great
drawer how about like an old did you
ever have a trophy like your first
[ __ ] no dude I think that no not
trophies or anything I've never felt
like attached to any of that stuff I
have a lot of [ __ ] actually thinking
about it what's another thing you got
yeah my mom I remember Build-A-Bear was
like a newer or newer at least in my
life I had no idea what it was and I
know we're still living in North Phoenix
so I must have been either third or
second grade but my mom made me this
little stuffed animal monkey named Leroy
and it has like this little where you
hit the thing and goes I still have it
it's in my camper right now that's time
we have a lot of stuff I have a lot of
stuff like that actually like presents
that I've gotten from my mom or like my
dad that I keep
yeah dude I'm trying to think of
anything that I have from a long time
ago because I used to move around a lot
too and I'm a very big like minimalist
so I love getting rid of [ __ ] like I
like that more than holding on to stuff
because if you lose it it's not not a
big deal because I'm so used to giving
away what's your best method of getting
rid of like when you're liquidating your
oh I donate I go to like Salvation Army
uh Goodwill or whatever and I just go
here's a couple bags of things I still
do it pretty often too especially with
clothes because yeah I don't know I just
feel like once I give it away now I have
more room to get new stuff so I always
keep things flowing you know feng shui
dude
you know one time at a at a Goodwill I
found a Quest Crew shirt
I saw Kendra's shirt too oh [ __ ] if I
would have saw a question I would have
bought that [ __ ] that's kind of tight
you guys didn't buy it no I didn't that
was too expensive though
anything like that are you are you just
like him or you just throw everything no
I'm a minimalist too but I would
probably say just running on the whole
first day thing there is so like me and
my fiance
um one of our first dates was we went
gun shooting that's dope my [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass my pipeline large people I I I
I I I wasn't the the gun person she's
the one that has all the guns no way
yeah so like we went to the LA Garden
Club and it was a pretty cool like you
know those things that you shoot into it
was pink with a black background and we
were just shooting on one of the targets
and it was just all in the chest and the
head was perfect and I was like hey why
don't you just try to do like a headshot
and so she took one shot and there's
like a bullet like right here that went
through it I was like oh I'm gonna frame
them
that's cool as fun reason why I've never
I've never left her too because I don't
know what's gonna happen
but yeah it's like it will probably go
with me to every house that I moved to
because it's like a cool little piece
and you just got like one shot in in the
fourth and it's like a heart shape no
dude that's bad that's a good one I'm
gonna put a bull home like oh my God
what do you got so when me and my lady
got married there's a picture that we
took outside of the um where we were
staying it was like a really cool
tropical like backdrop drop of flowers
and then we have a picture framed but
then she had some artists uh do their
own sketch of it and it's like a cool
stylized version of it and I think
that's a a really cool piece that we
have that we kind of share together but
that's pretty much it besides that I
don't think there's anything that like
I do have one thing that my mom gave me
that I think is now sentimental but I
haven't had it for that long and it's
this uh bracelet it kind of looks like
this but it's all like uh tiger's eye
beads because she had like it she had it
blessed by like a monk or whatever and I
didn't even know that right and so when
I would wear it my friend that was a
monk came over and he's like oh [ __ ]
this has a lot of energy it's probably
blessed by a monk and just he could just
tell by picking it up I was like huh and
then I asked my mom like oh she she did
so it's weird how there's like this item
with like spiritual energy in it I'm
like I think I'm gonna keep this like
for a good while and then you give it to
Google huh no no no I actually still
have it I didn't wear it today but
that's like one of the things I think
I'm Gonna Keep like and hold on to
especially because my mom gave it to me
that is yeah does your family do that
like keep stuff you know what I I think
my I inherited my mom's like Keepsake
mentality but then my dad is highly like
get rid of it this episode is brought to
you by audible oh yeah you know what
I've been really interested in these
days what
real estate
and uh I've been listening to this
podcast because a lot of my real estate
agent friends are like you gotta up your
game you gotta understand what the
hell's going on because you know you got
all kinds of investment strategies you
got long-term rentals you got short-term
rentals you got midterm rentals you got
all these different you got you can buy
and sell you can flip you can wholesale
I'm like man that's so much [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] starting from zero so they
recommended a podcast called Bigger
Pockets oh Bigger Pockets I like those
guys so I've been listening religiously
and especially on my runs because I've
been trying to get my weight down so
I've been jogging all the time and it
helps out because as I'm listening to
people talk I realize like running
doesn't get as boring and I don't feel
that I'm getting tired so I just run
like 30 minutes and I'll still take me
like two runs to finish one full podcast
and it's convenient because now all the
stuff that I listen to is in one place
all the Bigger Pockets there and also I
have uh my audiobooks when I'm driving
from Vegas to LA back to Vegas so that's
why I love audible audible is the home
of Storytelling and I love learning
through stories because I never really
did well with textbooks and I never did
well with lectures that are boring it's
just like a checklist that they're going
through and when someone can like
explain to me and things like a story
like I'm a bit of a child you know I
want to learn about Jack and Jill like I
want to learn about you know three guys
walking to a bar and tell me a story and
then I memorize it better yeah if you
just talk at me I don't learn I don't
but if I'm hearing two people talk or I
hear a story then my brain understands
and also audible doesn't only have
audiobooks like they have podcasts they
have comedy shows they have a lot of
great content let audible help you
discover new ways to laugh Be Inspired
or be entertained new members can try it
free for 30 days visit audible.com off
the Record or text off the Record to
500-500 that's audible.com off the
Record or text off the Record to 500-500
to try audible free for 30 days
audible.com off the Record see both of
my parents are like keep it so like my
dad has Con tickets from the first
concert he ever took us to oh that's
great and then like stuff that like I I
made my mom in like third grade or so
that's called hoarding No my great my
grandma sometimes can kind of be on the
little hoarding side but uh no it's just
like little things like I made my mom
this little incense holder of this like
wiener dog she still has it she still
uses it as an instant thing but yeah my
dad has like a lot of the concerts and
like pictures of the concerts and yeah
and then like stuff for uh oh I guess
it's different but like our dogs that
have passed away right like we still
have like their collars with their names
yeah so that's gonna make me cry bro
yeah they're they're fingernail
clippings nah
[Laughter]
I think you really do inherit that
behavior from your parents 100 yeah yeah
because my mom was really she was really
big on keeping everything like when my
parents got married they were gifted
like a bunch of like weird uh like I
think they got married in like the 70s
so all the gifts were like 70s
appliances like microwaves that all look
retro and stuff and all of that was in a
giant stack in the tool shed till I was
like in my 20s and I was like are you
ever gonna plug these things in and my
mom's like Oh I just like them you know
like she didn't want to let him go my
dad was like let's get rid of them but I
like it actually just thinking about so
I was just in Arizona right and my
grandma when my great grandma passed my
grandma got the house right and so she's
had it for a long time and then she
finally got to the point because it's
super far from everybody and she didn't
want to sell it because like none of us
wanted to get rid of it because like we
grew up in that house right and so we
finally got to that point because she
was unhappy there to where everybody's
like all right didn't sell it and you
know move be happy and she moved close
to a family but because like she doesn't
really get rid of stuff there's a lot of
old school stuff from like my great
grandma and my great grandpa who I never
really met but like he used to work on
these telephone lines and so like they
used to have these old school phones
these orange ones had these two
connectors that they would plug onto the
top of the the line and make phone calls
with so I got that but I'm hell into
bullying and my great grandma was a huge
bowler and just this past week and I was
out there we found her old uh bowling
bag and I had one old bowling balls and
like these old school like Dexter
bowling shoes that are like in like mint
condition and they fit my little sister
perfectly so she now has them but then
it has her little Chamois and her uh
ball waxer and it has all of her patches
on it so I'm like oh I get to keep this
so I'll probably have that I'll have
that forever and there's like a head in
the bowling bag there's a pad in the
bowling bag put it in the fridge yeah no
but gosh I think it's cool that I'm
happy that we do that because then we
find stuff like that you know like we
have a bunch of stuff my mom has a bunch
of stuff for my great grandma in this
little case that we have like these
little there was like this Little Gnome
that my great grandma bought when my mom
was like four and gave it to my mom and
she's had it ever since then and just
like a bunch of stuff like that you know
what's funny is I think like I wonder if
you have the same thing that I do like
mildly where I feel like I barely dodged
a hoarder personality because as a kid I
remember being kind of like like I had
empathy for inanimate objects sometimes
yeah I know I like to keep saying yeah
like the feeling of getting rid of
something even if it wasn't [ __ ]
alive I would just be like huh I feel
that too but it's like even more music
like when you listen to a certain song
and you can like remember exactly how
you felt or what you were doing that day
same exact thing for me with like
objects right so like I can grab it I
was like oh I remember when I got this
like this person gave it to me that's
why you got a Marie condo it remember
that when you [ __ ] Marika you gotta
[ __ ] say thank you to appreciate its
existence as you give it dude once I
watch that I learned how to throw away
[ __ ] it was crazy right I [ __ ] condo
the [ __ ] out of my spot like that like
if I can get really attached to things
that I yeah will never use ever again
for no reason exactly but functionality
wise I'm like dude I just can't have
this I don't have the space to keep this
well you know what also messed it up as
a kid is if you saw Brave Little Toaster
as a child you're gonna walk around with
this complex where like I used to really
believe that like when I was a kid
I believe that like my possessions were
thinking about me when I was like
neglecting and they were and like what
if I like moved away and forgot them
like Toy Story oh like Toy Story yeah
yeah
so I was a kid I was like oh man
oh man I'm on my toaster to come running
after me
damn that's trippy because when you see
that Brave Little Toaster did a number
on you man it really gave like nice
little personality she just inanimate I
have no idea Toy Story Did It For Me Toy
Story yeah bro because you see the pain
and suffering in their eyes yo wasn't
Andy [ __ ] so what happened to all
your toys you know actually I think uh
they're at my mom's house like in the
garage you never got rid of them I'm
pretty sure it's still there I think I
threw away like a like most of it but I
think there's like a small little box of
just like but it's cool to keep that
stuff because like when you guys have
kids you can give those toys to your
kids and be like I used to play with
this when I was a kid that's true yeah
that is really cool some some things I
wish I hoarded a little better is like
collector item things like like Pokemon
cards and Magic Gathering or pogs even
you know or like of a cultural type of
like thing because and they're
considered like Collectibles because you
know you never know when a collectible
is going to be collectible right yeah no
yeah like Pokemon we used to have so
much Pokemon cards we used to have
literal Pages where we'd set our
holographic ones and stuff and they're
all mint condition and we just threw
that [ __ ] out like we literally threw it
in the trash here like we don't want to
play I still have mine but I think
they're all worth nothing
well like remember I told you my Dad
recently found my my uh Kobe rookie
cards that I didn't even know I still
had okay those are gonna be crazy
they've got to be gone and my dad's like
no they're right here my whole thing I
had the Kobe Beckett still in mid
condition the one of him on the cover
all that stuff yeah and it's never been
taken out of its first plastic sleeve
that I put it
to the 90s the values fluctuate like
crazy on eBay there's like some wishful
thinking that'll it's like to the five
figures but then you'd have to get it
graded at that point and even then like
who knows who's gonna buy it at that
price oh yeah but they are some old old
cards like Kobe rookie rookie dude you
should get him a praise they don't even
take good pictures of them yet because I
don't know if that he's a big deal dude
you should you should see because those
are probably gonna be worth crazy
amounts of money no they're not gonna be
worth much I'll give you 50 bucks for
them now for the whole binder they were
worth a ton like the week after he had
passed the prices were like insane and
then they've leveled out to just being
like in the thousands or hundreds still
pretty good ungrade ungraded get them
graded see what's up it's not that hard
though to get them graded yeah because I
just went to a card store because when I
was a kid I'd always go to Hall of Fame
in Monrovia if you guys ever heard of
that place
um and they moved they moved to like uh
what's that downtown area in Monroeville
Myrtle oh yeah and I was like eating
lunch I was like oh crap dudes Hall of
Fame so I went in there and then because
I have this uh Hakeem Olajuwon Jersey uh
when I was a kid one of my
aunts lived like pretty close to
accumulation and this was during the
Olympics so I bought an Olympic jersey
and we went to his house and I just
stood in front of his house for a while
oh [ __ ] and he actually pulled up in
this like little C-Class Mercedes which
this was like probably like early 90s
right early mid 90s
um and he pulled up like he was trying
to get into his gate and I was like can
you sign this and he actually signed it
so I was asking the guys like hey look
like I have this jersey it's in a frame
and everything like that like how much
is it worth He was like well you need to
get like authenticated if he really
wanted to be worth anything he said it
was only like 60 bucks so I don't think
it's like that expensive yeah it's it's
weird because like there you gotta like
give it to the place they ship it out
your card or whatever and then depending
on how fast you want it back the price
is no different it's like 300 bucks if
you want to get it like right away or
something it's crazy it's like 60 if you
want it back in like a month or some
[ __ ] that's a scam it's a little bit
scary I don't know but I guess if
everybody does it and that's the norm
then that's how they do it but I was
like maybe I'll just wait till one of
those uh card shows comes to town and
they have like grading live on this yeah
oh that's what they that's what they
usually do Comic Cons yeah the great
comic books oh they do it over there
yeah and trading cards too at least I
have a bunch of comic books too like old
school comic books like Terminator ones
and [ __ ] they were like perfect you just
never know what's gonna be worth
anything the craziest thing is expecting
a kid to not open the toy or not open
the packaging that's insane like can you
imagine that getting a Nintendo game
like oh but don't open it might be worth
a lot like there's no way that's where
you guys gotta buy two but yeah I think
that's a nice little Crossover with like
sentimentality kind of pays off in that
way of like you don't want to throw
something away and luckily if your
generation before you behave that way
then you get a lot of gems too you know
it's really cool I do have some uh Daft
Punk action figures that I'll never open
and I have too many Daft Punk bear
bricks as well in the box that I'm never
gonna open as well that's pretty sick
though I know you're a big Daft Punk guy
huh a little bit I have no idea
interesting dude if there was any Daft
Punk oh my God
what's Daft Punk
[Laughter]
what's Daft Punk
everybody uh respond in the comments
below they they go where is that funny
oh I know yo that was ripped me out
[Music]
foreign